hello freak [ __ ] it's it's super
complex and I guess that makes sense it
makes sense that it would be now when
someone boils it down to something
that's really woo like you know what in
the bleep do we know but how is that
very frustrating to you like what does
it mean that must make you communicating
with people that have seen that and have
these ideas that are false assumptions
based on it sort of like I'd said to you
that atoms are mostly hollow yeah what
does that frustrating I mean what is
that line it's frustrating at different
levels you know I think I my first
impulse is to be charmed and happy when
people care people are even interested
on positive yeah like I first want to
give people credit and see if there's
something inside them with that we can
work with and try to work toward the
truth right
but then yeah so and I think most people
maybe are like that and some hardcore
people who have made up their minds
about the craziness I mean you see where
it would come from right because quantum
mechanics says what the world is is
different than what we see when we look
at it so it's a small leap from that
correct statement to we bring the world
into existence by looking at it right
bro then you're Deepak Chopra and Deepak
he's found me on Twitter so whenever I
tweet something about quantum mechanics
he you know retweets it with something
but it's all in your mind it's all
consciousness bringing the world into
existence he loves word salad yeah that
guy is the biggest like dealer of worlds
word salad yeah the world is everything
this is putting them the word salad into
a recipe that people think this
nutritious for them right they really
like to eat even though there's no
actual nutritional value well there's
you get a lot of that from like certain
yoga classes like there's certain yoga
classes that I go to where like the yoga
teacher will start talking some woowoo
[ __ ] and like you're be in the middle of
the pose and like what is this guy going
on about as long as the pose is helping
me I'm gonna put up with that yeah I
smile my way through it but it's weird
that that stuff is all can excited
that's all sort of kind of in that sort
of genre of people that are trying to
improve their life or be spear
- or they love that Deepak Chopra [ __ ]
like I've had that I had this
conversation with a friend of mine who's
like you give me a Deepak Chopra book
and I started going through it now it's
like I go you know this guy's crazy
right probably wants to do well it's
probably not a terrible person probably
wants to do well but he's also ignoring
the actual scientists that study all
this stuff and he's sort of pitching
this thing that what what it is like
this Deepak Chopra ISM this sort of like
spiritual pseudo quasi spiritual view of
the world that he's pitching - like
these these middle-aged housewives yeah
they're like looking for some sort of a
meaning to life but they don't like
going to church yeah and Daniel Dennett
the philosopher came up with a great
word for it he calls them deputies when
you string some words together in a way
that sounds extremely profound but you
look closely at it and doesn't actually
mean anything at all you know there's a
website that will do that for you oh the
Deepak Chopra quote yes there's another
website that comes up with random
physics paper titles it's not that the
physics stuff is it's almost beat I
guess there's there's similar issues
with the reason why Deepak can do that
is because most people don't understand
what he's talking about
so if you say a lot of stuff about
things that people don't understand like
I've had weave there's been a bunch of
videos that we played on this podcast
about fake martial arts practitioners
there's a whole business in these people
that have these fake martial arts
techniques and they use all these huge
words that are very very rare about the
central nervous system and about the you
know the structure of the body and
they'll they'll use all this stuff to
try to get you think like oh well this
guy obviously is a enormous vocabulary
and a deep understanding of anatomy
he must therefore be this and she
mastered that he's pretending to be it's
kind of very similar so I kind of
recognized that pattern in the woowoo
people like oh I kind of see what you're
doing you're throwing a bunch of very
complicated word that aren't in most
people's vernacular and you're saying
them in a way that makes me feel like
you have some sort of a connect
to the the Chi and to the chakras and to
the the inner or whatever that
everybody's trying to reach to be happy
yeah and another problem is just that
whenever there is a field whether it's
physics or medicine or whatever where we
know something
but it's hard complicated
counterintuitive when we explain it we
translate it right you know in physics
we have mathematical equations that are
quite unambiguous as to what they say
but then we use words we say well
there's a cloud there's a probability
etc and every translation is inaccurate
in some sense so if you were basing your
beliefs off the translations then you
can fudge them a little bit more to get
almost wherever you want to go
[Applause]
[Music]